hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in his short work
notes from underground Fyodor Dostoevsky
draws a contrast between two
fundamentally different kinds of people
who live in the same world but who
experience it quite differently and
react to it and think about it in very
different ways and the contrast here is
between the narrator who portrays
himself as an intellectual and in
particular an intellectual of the 19th
century and we'll talk about whether or
not that applies to later centuries as
well the contrast is between the
intellectual and what he calls at
various points the ordinary person or
the man or person of action or them the
man of character the person who has some
sort of fixed comportment you could say
a set of values that they follow a set
of commitments they know where they
stand in the world they may in fact be
going down and dying and some blaze of
glory or in some miserable foxhole but
at least they know where they are they
may be trying to gamble and
when big and they may in fact lose or
they may attempt to marry well or fight
a duel but in any case they're doing
something and this would apply to not
just people and the nobility but all the
way down to the peasant at one point
Dostoevsky 'he's character talks about
this person as recognizing where the
walls are and looking at them quite
stolid Lee and and not trying to you
know keep bashing themselves against it
because the the wall has a sort of
soporific effect but where there's an
open vista well they act they do things
they exert themselves the intellectual
is very different from this and
Dostoevsky is going to call this sort of
person by a lot of different names they
are reflective they think about things
reflective not just in the sense of
paying attention but thinking things
over mulling them over ruminating upon
them they're intelligent they can they
can see further they can draw inferences
and understand assumptions that the
other people can't they have a what he
calls a heightened consciousness that's
a term that he uses at several points in
in this work what does that mean to have
a heightened consciousness they are
aware of more they take in more than the
ordinary person the person of action or
character does and so when we get down
to what are they aware of well let's
take a look at some of the
characterizations in the text very early
on he talks about himself this character
he says I am a sick man I'm a mean man
there's nothing attractive about me and
he goes on and he says really I don't
understand anything about my sickness
I'm not even too sure what it is it's a
lling me I'm morbidly superstitious you
may say that I refused medical help
simply out of contrary
I don't know about that but I've been
living like this a long time he's
somebody who in a certain respect
recognizes how crazy and contingent this
world is and yet at the same time it is
a world in which there are good things
valuable things and he understands how
difficult it is to have them how
contingent those are and how much he
fails to measure up to them he doesn't
think highly of himself and he goes on
he talks a little bit about the job that
he that he used to have and his
conflicts and then he goes on and he
says that for everyday needs the average
person's awareness is more than
sufficient
now the intellectual is suffering from
not a deficit but a surplus a surplus of
something that is at the same time
negative he says to great lucidity is a
disease a true full-fledged
disease why he says it's about 1/2 1/4
the the average person's awareness of
the unhappy 19th century intellectual
particularly if he's unfortunate enough
to live in Petersburg the most abstract
and premeditated city on earth
there are premeditated and
unpremeditated cities now what he's
saying here could apply just as well
through our own time particularly in
this this hyper connected time of the
internet where if somebody wants to be
an intellectual they have an access to
information coming from all different
sources that would be almost
unimaginable even in dostoevsky's time
what the intellectual is is experiencing
is a sort of ruthlessness a sort of
ungrounded miss and we're going to
explore some other important aspects but
it let's see what else he says he says
the extent of conscious
at the disposal of what may be termed
the spontaneous people and men of action
is quite sufficient I'm not going to
take a crack at them what happens when
you are hyper conscious well you grasp
how much you fail to measure up if
you're not you know that intelligent you
might actually think that you're a
decent person you might actually think
that you measure up to the true the good
the beautiful these ideals that we place
out there you might even think that you
fit into the ideal of the group or the
religion or political association or
pick whatever else it is the bowling
league you might even think that you're
you know something that you're not with
respect to something as seemingly
trivial as that you might think that
you're great at your job you might think
that you're OK at your job and that's
that's quite good enough because you
don't need to measure yourself against
anyone else you might buy into all sorts
of new agey self helpy things as well if
you're not all that bright
Dostoevsky is saying that's enough it'll
work for you and you're not going to be
bothered by a lot of qualms you find
you're as we say you find your bliss and
you stick with it all right
so he goes on this is in Section three
and when he's talking about you know
getting angry and taking revenge and all
those sorts of things he says that
ordinary people are able to handle that
the normal person gets angry and they
think that they're you know just in
doing that but the intellectual is more
like a mouse he calls him a test-tube
product rather than a child of nature he
says that he's so subdued by his
antithesis that he views himself
heightened consciousness and all as a
mouse rather than as a man even if he's
a mouse of the heightened consciousness
he's still nothing but a mouse whereas
the the other is a man and why is he
being humiliated over and over again
because any sort of course of action
that he looks at seems insufficient
it seems contingent it might work it
might not work
why should he try it even if he does
succeed it's not really going to produce
the results that he's looking for he's
smart enough to know that this can apply
just as well to the romantic life right
should I ask this person out should I go
dance with them very popular thing back
then should I introduce myself should I
put myself out there should I take a
chance well if I do who knows what
that's going to lead to well actually I
can project what it's going to lead to I
can think of 50 different possibilities
and any one of them could be what
happens and none of them are truly going
to make me happy because even the
happily ever after well I know that
that's really a pipe dream I'm realistic
about these sorts of things whereas the
ordinary person is quite romantic and
can go off and do that same thing with
the workplace should I take this kind of
job should I take this kind of job the
person who's the intellectual knows that
all the jobs suck in one way or another
so they understand the contingency the
falseness of any action that they might
take and this produces something like a
paralysis an inertia is how Dostoevsky
puts it the net result of this is that
the intellectual as he says is unable to
truly be anything he is not able to make
him or herself into something that they
can actually call by something he says I
couldn't manage to make myself nasty nor
for that matter friendly crooked or
honest a hero or an insect I can't make
myself into anything I'm trying to live
my life in a corner consoling myself
with a stupid useless excuse that an
intelligent man cannot turn himself into
anything only a fool can make anything
he wants out of himself and he feels
that he's spineless because of
this he can't make himself into anything
that he can strictly identify with or
commit to why in part because he
realizes there's so many other
possibilities and he also realizes that
anything that he does he's sort of
playing it he's not totally committed to
it he could have done differently he
still can do differently although
Dostoevsky is not using this term at
this point the intellectual is conscious
of a freedom that the ordinary person is
not conscious of so they're unable to be
anything there's another passage later
on quite quite funny where he talks
about laziness and he says if only my
doing nothing were due to laziness how I
respect myself then why why would you
respect yourself as somebody who is lazy
he says well I would know that I could
be lazy at least that I have at least
one definite feature in me something
positive something to be sure of people
could ask who is he and the response
could be a lazy man and he would know
who he really is the intellectual unlike
everybody else doesn't really know who
they are and that plagues him it
introduces as he says a strange state
that is a sort of inertia he talks in
another passage about how the ordinary
person you know is able to do things
because they're not plagued by all these
questions and doubts and another way he
puts this is they don't see the
difference between primary and secondary
causes right and but the intellectual
person unfortunately does so they see
how things work and they realize that
acting for example in terms of revenge
or romance or the workplace or prestige
among friends or whatever it happens to
be a noble gesture never really fulfills
the promise
it seems to make so that's a problem
this introduces a kind of incapacity to
act if you know that nothing really
means anything then why not succumb to
inertia his laziness is not his inertia
is not actually laziness he says a
little bit later on he brings up this
inertia again at the very end and he
says it's best to do nothing at all
conscious owner she is the best a toast
to my hole under the floor and though it
was said that I was green with envy of
the normal man I still wouldn't take his
place under present circumstances though
I'll go on envying him and he's
justifying the inertia that he succumbs
to there's two other features that we
could say our characteristic of the
intellectual as Dostoevsky is
constructing him here reflectively in in
the underground man one is that the the
intellectual is able to take pleasures
in things that we might consider
perverse or morbid for example he says
that well you know people can take
pleasure in a toothache haven't you ever
heard an intellectual suffering from a
toothache that groans that they make and
he also says that despair itself
provides a certain kind of pleasure the
despair of realizing that the world is
divided up into people who actually know
what's going on or at least think they
know what's going on and can't do
anything and can't be anything and then
all the other fools out there who
there's something a little bit admirable
about them they're able to do something
they're able to be something even though
it's really quite you know silly and
they aren't what they think that they
are they don't have any idea what
they're really doing the world is
divided up into these two classes and
neither one of them is really fulfilled
according to Dostoevsky
and the intellectual Kant will him or
herself into the other class even if
they wanted to so they take a kind of
pleasure in that despair the last thing
is that he accuses himself by placing
this in the mouth of the would-be reader
of engaging in a kind of cowardice but
he's not even a coward the cowardice of
the intellectual is not the cowardice of
the person who's chronically afraid no
it's a different kind of cowardice a
cowardice that postures a cowardice that
comes out of the Mousehole every so
often and stakes out a claim but does so
ironically does so seemingly making a
commitment but not able to truly do so
and whenever it does make a commitment
it realizes that this is a purely
contingent act and that it may totally
backfire and doesn't mean anything
anyway so this is a pretty dismal
picture of what the intellectual is like
in late modernity st. Petersburg is you
know sort of an emblem of this but we
could think about any other city on
earth and I think with the internet that
you're accessing this right now we could
talk so much about this happening at any
given place so another way of talking
about this is the intellectual is
conscious of the absurdity of existence
particularly the existence of the
intellectual him or herself
you